If Grant invests $10,000 at a 3% annual rate compounded twice a year, then in 6
months, he'll receive 1.5% on this $10,000 investment. This means that $150.00
will be added to his account, in interest. The total balance will then be
10,000 plus 150, or $10,150. After six more months pass, Grant will again
receive 1.5% interest, but now on this new amount. The interest added this time
will be 0.015 times 10,150, or $152.25. This will make the total amount of
money in the account after one year equal to $10,302.25. Note that in the
second six months, more interest is added, since Grant is getting interest on
the interest from the previous six months, as well as on his original
investment. Seems like a pretty good deal to me.